[Music]
an infant consent Natak of the
blue-haired people again I hope it's not
I can't I can't you don't anymore TIFF
you're doing the right thing you know
what your your trigger then your pixie
knee you cut that [ __ ] off your pixie
Nina vixeny yeah submitted by DS g DJ
Jazzy Jeff oh cool I don't know you
watched oh that's right yes a sexuality
educator is suggesting that parents
should ask their babies for permission
to change their diapers amazed there now
they're wet nappies
I agree like how do you how does a baby
respond tyka lets me I agree because I
don't want to have to change a diaper
unless the baby told me to do it there
you go yeah they can live with the [ __ ]
just let it chill yeah all right so this
sexuality educator expert named Dina how
do you get that license you just have to
be dumber than [ __ ] this is the right
way to do it there you go yes she was on
this ABC News segment that families
could set up a culture of consent in
their homes by asking their babies first
it like you know I'm going to change
your nappy is that okay so I'm gonna
show you guys our [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
it's super quick and Easter colors
exactly okay Wow I'm gonna change your
nappy now is that okay of course the
baby's not gonna respond yes ma'am
that's awesome I'd love to have my
nephew changed but if you leave a space
and wait for body language and wait to
make eye contact then you're letting
that child know that their response
matters okay so what she's saying is not
really looking for yes or no but start
conditioning them to feel that
there were they kidding me okay that
makes more sense than [ __ ] people
should ask their babies I'm like really
doing it baby
imagine you're at Disneyland the kid is
screaming right because he's that got a
poopy diaper or whatever it should it
rash in his butt or whatever right and
then you got to [ __ ] throw the kid
onto one of those tables in like a
shitty crowded bathroom and it smells
terrible and then you also have to give
the speech is this okay that I do this
dude I'm like the opposite I think
babies and children should just shut the
[ __ ] up and listen I agree because I
tried that with Isaac so I raise Isaac
asking him like hey so what do you want
like what do you want to eat you want to
eat this you don't eat that and I always
gave him a lot of options cuz I thought
that that would make him more
independent like you know he can have no
they just control the [ __ ] out of you so
that's what kind of end up happening
where he's just like you know he has his
set ways and it's just kind of back for
him the parents job is to challenge the
kid and to push them to do things that
they won't usually you know that that's
what happens kids in public screaming
and hitting their parents and the
parents are like you need to calm down
like oh no I would never let go it never
happen in my family but you need to
lower your voice the kids like you need
hey you need to stop you need to stop
and the level of patience is crazy
I could never that's what you just go I
love you so much
so much you just keep hugging them until
they fall I'm not saying abuser chill
Emma I'm not for like that I'm for just
you know but make your boy stur and like
let them know that you're in charge
that's definitely true cuz like now when
Isaac I tell them like okay Isaac now
say I'm gonna go shower or whatever he's
just like no or not even that it'll be
like dinner time and then I'll tell
Casey I'm like hey can you tell him to
eat the veggies or whatever and in
Casey's just so we're so used to asking
him like hey do you want to eat the
veggies it's not your choice boy no no
more choices like we try that you want
to eat the veggies of something you
actually asked him before
like him had the best life ever it's
pretty crazy
I will say given a choice I loved
broccoli that was my favorite food yeah
I think really loves veggies I thought I
love broccoli because my mom would put
Kraft American cheese all the [ __ ] over
yeah like crap American cheese that's
goddamn right and then I found that with
real bra commuters and I was like no I
don't like this no no he's dead like
veggies but yeah what do you ask him if
he likes babies like this just an
example
finish it yeah or even like just
actually to get him to do things I would
always ask him first like hey do you
want to do this and now I'm not doing
that anymore I'm just like hey you got
to do this like now you just have to
learn that you just need to listen what
I mean mom no no no I agree man you got
to just like my mom was never like do
you guys want it's like we're having
beef stroganoff tonight okay little
[ __ ] like who is this that's how what
one I mean all these people that are
creating these rules I wonder if they
have kids and I wonder if they you know
went through this because it's funny if
they're like single never had kids and
they're creating all these [ __ ] yeah
what experience are you speaking they're
going through this no the kids that I'm
talking about in the public like in
Beverly Hills that are like screaming
and wailing on their parents and the
parents are just like they learned in
their little class to be like you need
to lower your voice hey that's not how
we speak that's not how it's like we
have to mediate the situating its head
up and hitting you like you need to grab
his hands and be like no we do not hit
unlike a good indicator of what timeout
that I have any kids
well good indicator from what I've been
observing is a good indicator of what
type of parent you're gonna be is if you
own dogs like how your dog treats you
and that relationship that you have with
them is is what I've noticed to be a
really good indicator really yeah cuz
then like you'll see it like people that
have dogs that are [ __ ] hella yappy
or like just walk all over them and do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do that
usually kind of translate over to who's
like their kids that's what I never
thought of it I can't wait to be at a
friend's house because I have so many
friends with ill-behaved dog yeah yeah
check it out cuz I people already aren't
a fatal relationship with their dog and
their dog is actually the Alpha my cat
hits me in the face all's well cats are
I don't know about cat-like eyes
Catherine is evil the only gets me
though he loves me
yeah I've grown up with cats and I can't
say that that relationship is the same
like cats are just on their own yeah but
they're their own thing but like dogs
are like children because there's a
pecking order yeah cats think that
you're one of them that's why they think
they see you as an equal they don't see
you as like their yeah they don't care
about you you should write a book about
just dogs no just like good dog good kid
bad dog Maxie on The Today Show already
with a [ __ ] book called theory on
parents and don't you dare
no just class it up a little bit you
gotta wear the real killing that turns
Bart on too so it's even better and then
you saw in the dictionary like well yeah
I'll see you never saw it in like so
this is how you parent your kids oh yeah
what I do like is when I see those
parents that have so much established
that they have shorthand so you know
usually it's like okay
they shut up be quiet go to your room or
whatever like you have to give like all
these instructions but I feel like the
really experienced parents that I've
seen they're just like Riley stop they
stop your finger and the kids already
like putting [ __ ] in their backpack I
know I'm [ __ ] up I'm gonna get ground
like like what did I say don't even up
Aires we have to say anything they just
go just look at him and the kids like oh
[ __ ] I already did like their own
[ __ ] rope and discipline dude that's
actual discipline yeah they already know
like what time it is
yeah so this child behavior expert named
Natalie Brown she was commenting on what
this sexuality expert was saying they'd
either bring in like a Asian child
expert no so there's a school age a
child expert is like how to get your
children to resent you and never this is
extreme light right then the Asian is
extreme [ __ ] love are the other way
the other way yeah yeah Savannah Natalie
brown was saying babies do not know a
permission is and so trying to teach it
a young child about consent in this
situation is wrong if parents didn't
change their child's and happy every to
be abuse they would be a country full of
kids with soiled nappy and if this was a
she called neglect and it's abuse yes
she goes into saying you have a duty of
care as a parent duty or adult when
you're looking after kids sometimes as a
parent you have to make decisions that
are in the best interest of your child
whether that is changing their nappies
feeding they were putting them to sleep
there are some things I just have to be
done despite the child's reaction and so
I'm sure pink haired lady is just took a
snippet out of that entire what you just
said and said teaching your children
consent is wrong you know I'm saying you
know they're too little to even
understand what consent is they don't
even know what their feet are they look
at their feet one danda like oh [ __ ]
wrinkles yeah he's blown away right now
yeah and then you show him a light
bright in there like yeah dude he like
walks off with the [ __ ] captain
doesn't understand that he's like
walking to his doom how's he gonna know
what the [ __ ] consent is that shit's
crazy you don't even know what
yes-and-no is well that's about it
listen guys it's about you know teaching
them through through example like or
through the through the eye contact and
that is this okay thing is supposed to
develop some kind of a synergy in their
brain will they learn consent well I
think through example I put Tycho right
here and I go hey babe do I have your
consent to have sex and he observes that
and then when we do have sex he
understands what the whole constructing
will see know do you ask for consent
sexually yeah he does actually does he
really yeah he says can we have sex
tonight
oh that's true yes really yeah cuz he
needs his plea need to see what he's
gonna put it in wouldn't cuz if she's
grabbing my balls I don't know if she
wants a new car you see he said can we
have sex tonight not in the afternoon
not spontaneous little water moves you
trying to do I'm always trying to do to
me she might be grabbing my licking my
dick I know she wants a new car a new
purse or shall wants to have sex what
he's trying to get out let's go with the
[ __ ] phone Bruce Lee he will be like
I need to go lay down and I'm like okay
because he's like I have a head
all day I even go lay down and the next
day I'm like are we gonna do so he's
like yeah I try to do stuff with you
last night I'm like when I said I was
gonna go lay down in the room
I [ __ ] up that night I [ __ ] [ __ ] that
means sex this is a recent example and
she was like go lay down in the room
okay I didn't just say it on one
sentence like that yeah he said that I
had a headache on the right side of my
head all day yeah and then and then like
15 minutes later I was like I'm gonna go
lay down and then hello have sex with me
and like Jonna
survey says everyone agrees with me
[Music]